для щедрого застигання вже ним знай я
не обхідним троянду мене початкову
інформації
ще розумним url або механічне
заучування розуміння початкову
інформації досягається звик вона не
практичних завдань розрядом дорікала
перший клас розуміння суд настей
арифметичних день до дування або
уваги досягається шляхом продумана
система початкових завдань та кір реалізують
етапи підготовкою від знайомими та
закріплення на етапі підготовки роботи
до цього не арифметичних день до
вання і уваги вже не
викладати практично вправо на прикро
нею двох груп об'єктів
предмет виведення річкових фігур. в одну там
а ви краще немає зі стіни групи об'єктив
до демонстрації ріжте
вид практичних вправо за роздавання ви
матеріалом переходу ма доро за люду
маленьких
на цих продемонстрована
проілюстрована прикро не я то ви
покращення а також дуже і пити карімі
ством мешканця показувати всі елементи
групу об'єкті всі отримані в результаті
прикро не я-то часті ну групи
я казав і шилася про якщо ви краще не і
чистими
на доступному етапі знаємо ваня петля
ви ікона непрактичних роздавання
ви матеріалом повідомляємо а вже їм ще
практично ідеї образлива двох груп
адже об'єктів побачи а раз матричне
їжа давання заміню йому про бідну чиспа
лучник і словом до дати та димом утрьох
ручним знак я camp означає рифм
отіче діда дування складу і мури вниз
звуку зростання ним знака плюс і призначаємо
ще з запас серії внести оскільки його на
місцях знак стародавні а вам пасхи до і
розтушовано лего ручки знака ревнощів
залп із цієї складається з числами ж
кайми стоїть знак плюс я ви разом
адже буває різне і раптово
особисту ідею мабуть не й вигляд практично
де з роздатку ви матеріалом до розряду
вид по видних маленьких за видами на не
ще практично ідеї ви краще не
вид повідай про романтично 9 увагу
якопо дружини означає знак мінус
читаємо і записаний рівнів 100 виріс до чи
вже не маю спить карим листя вчителя
переходить і вигляд практичних diys
предметами а бога та матричними фігурами
вид малюнки в на я до них виймають
про демонстранти оголошення то ви краще
не до складу на вигляд по видних виразах
бурі настей на даному етапі
результати арифметичних гей та дування
ставити увагу
вже не заходять шляхом перелікування
об'єктів утриманий результат називаємо у
значення ви розум змите формування
лучник 2 і модель вання як широко ви
хрестову ти про процес розв'язування
сюжетних завдань на нас топ на мій етапі
вже не переходять вигляд демонстрації objet
на ній а то ви покращення групи і
матричний фігур абу сюжетних маленьких
до демонстрації
обидва знання ви краще не за дупу нові
види ризику до схематичної інтерпретації
арифметичний індії до давання то ж
увага звучу я але ще не піп ще не
викану it's загинеш сем і а добираються
я буду сюжетну малинку і на поки що до
схеми добирають малюнок
дуже і догоряючи до схеми виріс і на
поки добирають та ви виду на вигляд
схему тягну
лише з роком до ситуації століття їх треба
продемонструвати і всі об'єкти обидва ви
краще ти частий але групи об'єктив уже не
в чаті самостійно складати схеми ручних
для себе способом
обозу б допомогою кружки в 3 cut ники
втягнув обози допомогу та вид ризику так їм
пшоном
ми розгорнули з того її знак і про нову
програми я в 4 гіра елізу вати по ряду
7 треба про аналізувати ват і права
змусивши 6 то результативно частими
програми ви означає і харчування кіпру пану
it is мытую реалізації вибір ідеального
навчання
то вправо джин де франсіонного підходу
і наперед батчат багато результату
треба ваги вати цих результатів впреві
в чині пивну теми травня до всіх ти все вже
не
Оскільки підручник за вийшов і зі старим
і
то на стоп ним крихтах дати сильно про
аналізу вати і змістимо і пити ручнику ви
значить і завдання та генний вигляд
побачилася програми то ви краще ти їх
tab p1000 дістати новини підручний кузов
данина для отримання результату
прописаних у програмі і все не те за
плану ватару стежку цик завдань
і дали приступи ти до складу нею
календарного планування перед спочиванням
динаміку досі мене про громових
результативно у чині
дякую за увагу